hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today we're
gonna answer a question from Gerald with
one of my newsletter readers who was
asking about raising capital and
protecting your idea so Gerald wrote
insane I'm trying to bring a travel
product to market and that has a
potential to revolutionize the uber
sighted industry I'm already in
possession of a design patent my issue
is capital is a nondisclosure agreement
form the best way to protect my product
as I discuss my idea with potential
investors so thanks for the question
gerald from my background in bed the
venture capital industry hopefully
there's a few ideas I can share with you
to start off most VCS will not sign in
on the school trip agreement simply
because they're there seen so many
opportunities on a daily basis and so
many products and ideas are so similar
to each other that they would never sign
a nondisclosure agreement so that's
that's kind of step one you can have one
ready and you can ask them to sign it
but for the most part they're gonna say
no really what they're looking for is to
see if you have the plan in place or the
execute so a lot of people have great
ideas but they don't necessarily have
the the plan and the team in place be
able to follow through and turn that
idea into a real business in the venture
capitalists point of view they're being
pitched all the time with all sorts of
ideas and a lot of them are very similar
and 99% of them get rejected and then
once that make it through are the ones
that a have some momentum behind them so
it's not just an idea but you are able
to show that you have either customers
or media's talking about you you build
some kind of momentum up to separate
yourself from everybody else who's
pitching the same idea and also they
look at your team so you know
have has anybody done this before is it
just you or do you have people around
you who've who've been successful as
entrepreneurs who have built something
similar and have since I've had some
success doing it if you don't have
anybody on your team you can go look for
somebody on your team or you can also
build a board of advisers and it's a
loose affiliation with your company it's
not as strict as having a board of
directors but the people who are giving
you advice on how to grow your business
and if they'll lend their name to your
company it can help establish your
credibility with you when you go talk to
investors so you know angels might sign
it but if you look into a venture
capitalist point of view they're not
going to look at signing a nondisclosure
agreement your best bet really is time
to market so it's really only a matter
of time before somebody else goes and
runs with your idea so you want to get
it out there and start talking to
investors and try to get the money you
need to launch your business it doesn't
mean you go and post it all over every
internet forum and that's you know
broadcast exactly what you're doing but
you have to be a little bit more open
when you're talking to investors because
they've seen so many of these ideas and
they're like I'm not going to want to
talk to you if it means they have to
sign it on the scholarship really so
hopefully that helps drill for those of
you watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes me want to do more of these videos
for you guys and if you have a question
about what you know Gerald's question is
something similar or you have another
question about your business feel free
to leave it in the comments below I
always read those and try to respond to
as many as I can so thank you and I'll
see you on the next episode
you